schreibt mir gerne in die kommentare
obwohl ich diese ansicht vertreten
aber ich finde detektor kommentare
meistens deutlich hitziger als das tik
tok sell bei diesem thema hier
beispielsweise ein typ geschrieben tut
mal so als wären die kommentare der
suchverlauf von julian kuhn babys beauty
palace und die kommentare sind so
bodenlos teka ich habe mich von meinem
freund getrennt aber niemand glaubt mir
was jetzt julian doppelpunkt sie wird
man pausenlos dem die ja was machen
jetzt mit dem ganzen bio zu hause kann
man als berühmte person mit einem
normalen passagier flugzeug fliegen wie
gut passe ich zu wie wie glas und testet
das ist eigentlich der gute idee von
youtube video was machen wenn mein kind
fieber hat ich aber im urlaub wie geht
man fremd ohne dass sich jemand fotos
machen wie viel kindergeld muss ich
zahlen wenn nicht millionen
ferienhaus gerecht aufteilen
stimmt das mache jetzt wenn die ganze
immobilien paartherapie in meiner nähe
doppelpunkt welches haus sollte ich
lieber behalten
wie stellt man seinen guten ruf
wiederherstellen bewerben dass er so
krass wenn man jetzt so baby und julian
irgendwie beide sendungen sehen würde
irgendwie bei big brother drin oder
wegen dschungelcamp oder so frank rost
tutorial
beschreibe ich gute lieder trennung kim
kardashian und tanja us public
einzimmerwohnung in meiner umgebung jo
[Musik]
ich weiß also keine ahnung wie das jetzt
machen mit dem ganzen vermögen aber
janko muss dann echt mal schauen wo er
bleibt ganz deutschland sagt ich und
mein freund sind noch zusammen was tun
dass leute mich stimmt diese ganzen
theorien die verkaufe ich einfach schräg
wird man bei das dschungelcamp berühmt
wie ex freund eifersüchtig machen wie
kann ich fremd gehen ohne dass meine
kinder was mehr hat deutsche bahn
überwachungs geführt
viele meinen ja auch dass diese
paparazzi bilder von bibi mit ihrem
neuen da am bahnhof bewerbung von der
deutschen bahn für das neuprodukt
ihr kommt nicht klar wo bewerbe ich mich
für hilf mir wo bekomme ich günstige
einbauschränke
prominent getrennt bewerbung
allerdings habe ich auch noch andere
tipps heute vorbereitet und zwar dass
hier ich bin durch absichtlich nicht den
tod war gottlos schlecht neben der
trennung von biel und julian was ja
wirklich immer noch komplett social
media dominiert ging es auch bei gntm
nämlich krass herr mit irgendwelchen
vorwürfen und skandalen danzig gekommen
sind und heidi hat er einfach gesungen
und das sind ein paar kommentare dazu
tut mir leid aber ich treffe heute
leider keine töne für euch vier mal
neben hieße nicht ob das moses solcom
statement von heidi wo sie prosieben
selbst ex profis weil die autotune
ausgestellt haben jeder geht anders mit
der trennung von bibi und julia für
umgehört
nein aber danke dass du da war ich habe
heute leider keinen richtigen ton für
die linke ist echt nicht mehr so
schlecht nur der charakter ziehe das
direkt im kopf er muss sie wirklich
lieben wenn er sie bei dem lied
unterstützt wir sind so verloren
es entwickelte sich ausgesucht haben ist
vor diesem typen der immer das gleiche
video hochlädt aber dann tags drauf
schreibt hier hat der website so
draufgeschrieben du weißt es wird
gottlos wenn du dich beim kacken
aussiehst ein handy weg legt sich nach
vorne lebens und gott fragt womit du das
verdient haben in den kommentaren kann
irgendwie jeder reden wenn du kurz
aufhörst zu drücken und all der aufwand
umsonst war der moment wenn das bein
anfängt zu zittern ihr leben echt alle
dasselbe leben natur als bürger darauf
gesehen aber ich für jeden einzelnen
kommentar ist es so krass wenn man weiß
man ist auf kommando und dann kommen
schon zerstört ich schwöre dabei fast
heulen wenn man aufhört zu drücken oder
dass der fortschritt wenn mein handy weg
legt dann ist wirklich ende im gefängnis
hier wird manchmal vom drücken
schwindelig und dann sich irgendwo fest
hält wo es kalt es damit die schmerzen
weniger werden wenn das passiert bricht
mein kreislauf meistens auch zusammen
und ich weiß nicht mehr ob ich scheiße
oder umkippen dann kommt das sind dann
in den beinen und die anschließenden
fliegenden sternchen in der luft die man
dann anfängt zu sehen er ist alles so
true und es ist auch nicht verwunderlich
dass der typen kommentiert haben
ich habe keine ahnung wie er gedacht
hätte das zu schaffen
edeka wir lieben lebensmittel die
frühschicht regelt das schon ich will
einfach gegangen ich wurde ohne grund
rausgeschmissen zum glück ist morgen
berufsschule war schon vorher kaputt
wenn ich gefragt werde wie knapp davor
ich bin mein studium zu schmeißen ihr
habt bei dem satzbau würde ich auch
direkt abbrechen sprachenlernen party
machen allerdings weiter mit dem
nächsten tik tok zu bibi und julian
denn bibi und ihr neuer typ wurden
zusammen italien gesehen
[Musik]
und unter diesem tik tok wo dann gefragt
wer fotografiert die denn die ganze zeit
leo
[Musik]
ich konnte nicht mehr
einfach das eigene kind was die
paparazzi bilder teils unter der sektor
wird übrigens auch noch geschrieben mit
zitrone und ich schwöre euch meine
komplette for you page ist voll mit
diesem schuss zitrone von barbie dann
dieses walla bruder film heute saß mit
kartellamtes hast schon mal gesehen die
20 leute mit gezogener waffe aufeinander
und bricht schlägerei aus und das was
mich am meisten aufregt ist dieses
enkelin lea hat ist nicht bekannt was
tags leute machen allerdings weiter mit
dem nächsten tik tok
[Musik]
wir sind alle gleich ich mache es an der
hose so seitlich so und nicht anders
spieltag ist wäre auch einfach
wasserverschwendung wenn man dann dieses
brötchen messer noch mal unter dem
wasserhahn halten würde ich mache das
einer mit einem küchenhandtuch
[Musik]
julia encke wird einfach in neuwied
gesichtet von den paparazzi da sollte
tatsächlich kein altes ort geben
versteht ihr schauen wir uns die
kommentare an meine lieben freunde und
zwar dort geschrieben junge h der arme
du machst bild mit ihm und er holt fast
junge dieses foto er hatte gar keinen
bock und kaufte dem junge neue hose
erträgt die seit zwei wochen das stimmt
es entweder sind alle paparazzi bilder
wirklich von leo gemacht worden am
gleichen tag und das ist alles ein
riesengroßer prank oder
[Applaus]
[Musik]
verbindung getrennt bitte versuchen sie
es nochmal meine träume der bre hat ping
9 milliarden
landwirtschaftssimulator aber real-tor
kennt ihr das wenn beispielsweise eure
eltern autofahren ihr sitzt hinten und
dann macht ihr mal egal ob es jetzt
abends oder tageweise so die augen
einfach zu stellt euch vor ihr seid oder
denkt man so in seinem viertel oder in
seiner stadt so mäßig so ok das heißt
wir müssten jetzt links abbiegen dann
sind wir jetzt da das wird recht macht
die augen auf und schickt dann okay da
sind wir gerade okay wenn du also wie
ich überlege ob 60 cent ein euro ist
oder 110 euro us dollar sogar alles
wegen uhr misst du sogar jetzt überlegen
oder ob eine minute 100 sekunden sind
jäger war mal kasse hatte 60 cent dabei
und wollte etwas für einen euro kaufen
auf einmal fehlt 40 das stimmt einfach
decker
warum sagt ihr nicht 60 cent sind ein
euro das sind 60 cent ein euro kommen
diese klasse rein
bäckerei aber sagen die mir jetzt völlig
das ist nicht echt dann ich gucke neben
klavier
[Musik]
dir wie du hast ein tag gefehlt genauso
eine klasse willich never let you next
move zu ernst genommen meine träume
steht ja auch wieder und mache gerade
selber eine ausbildung als
bäckereifachverkäuferin und da ist es
normal dass sowas hinten steht das frage
ich mich halt die toccata in erster
linie frage ich mich warum die
verdammten klassenzimmer einfach eine
bäckerei haben aber stimmt es wirklich
und da können gern alle leute die man
irgend einer bäckerei praktikum gemacht
haben oder ausbildungen oder keine
ahnung was gamer bezug nehmen und in den
kommentaren ist alles hinter dieser
glasscheibe beim bäcker fake
ich dachte nämlich immer das ist alles
irreal und wer soll das alles essen alle
die sagen das ist in den kommunen da
steht doch der box ihr habt euch
wahrscheinlich schon gefragt was das zu
beginn für ein komisches
war in diesem video und das hat auch
leonie kommentiert und zwar hast du
gefurzt und der erstattet sowie das hat
einfach antwortet neben eine muschel 8
im letzten tick tock für heute und zwar
wurde dort eine person im absoluten
sucht zustand gefragt was ein
anmachspruch bei mädels ist sein
bessermacher heute
listing von englisch schulaufgabe im so
für dich alles stehen arbeitet eher
zufällig bei vodafone und der hotline
ich verstehe dass der spruch klappt was
immer glaube ein paar buchstaben
vergessen hat noch kein glasfaserkabel
für das sprachzentrum also bei mir hätte
das safe gefruchtet er wird später mal
bei der bahn arbeiten genau das sage ich
auch immer der hat die sprache der sims
studiert an der stelle wird das heutige
wieder ist allerdings dann auch beenden
meine lieben freunde wenn euch meine
reaktion hierauf einige der lustigsten
ticker kommentare der letzten woche
gefallen hat hat ähnlich